What if this wasn't the life we were
meant to have after crisis
your mother's planning a trip
clark kent back in smallville
this family needs smallville as much as
the world needs superman
clark i need you to get to metropolis
now it's the boyce the boys
yeah honey your sons
front page news does this ever get old
if it does i will let you know
then the infinitude found release
and finally the darkness broke
filling it with life
with the multiverse
every existence multiplied by
possibility
and spread out before space and time
in infinite measure
civilizations rose and fell
and rose again across reality's grasping
expanse
life a precious gift persevering in the
face of every obstacle
until finally
the age of heroes was born
Welcome back everyone it's charlie so
they just dropped the first trailer for
the new superman series i'll explain
what's going on all the multiverse of it
all crisis on infinite earth's the
justice league easter eggs all the big
crossover stuff they have planned that
they've announced
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
a new amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know who's some of the big
villains and crossovers you want to see
during season 1 are
i'll just number these as we go along to
stay organized but starting with number
five
the show is basically going to be a
sequel series to smallville with tom
welling superman like if that show
had continued after he became superman
and put the suit on inserted the family
with lois
what would that have looked like so
tonally it will feel very similar
to smallville so if that was your jam
then you'll probably enjoy this show
more than say something like supergirl
or other superman based stuff that
they've done on tv so far
a lot of you also might be old enough to
have watched the lois and clark dean
kane series
way back when it was on during the 90s
that seems like a long time ago now but
it probably wasn't that long ago
obviously it's meant to be tyler
heckland's superman though so even
though i'm talking a lot about tom
welling's smallville and there'll be a
lot of comparisons and a lot of
similarities between the shows
if we do wind up seeing people from the
original smallville tv show
cameoing or coming back for the show
it'll either be as new characters or
if we see tom welling come back for
cameo scenes he would be coming as the
multiverse superman from his
earth there were a lot of multiverse
changes after a crisis on infinite
earths to their backstories on earth
prime so i'll explain that because they
reckoned a bunch of stuff about earth
prime superman for the purposes of
season one
but all the shows next year when they
start in january 2021 will be taking
place during the same time period for
the most part for the sake of continuity
and big crossovers like the flash
superman the big justice league
crossover stuff of it all the super
friends
that was what the crisis on infinite
earth's ending scene was all about like
them sitting at the table
grant gustin's flash basically showing
them the new hall of justice that he
decked out
so number four the basic premise of this
new superman show the story some of the
crisis on infinite earth's changes to
his backstory are that earth prime
superman before crisis started just had
baby john kent from the comics the new
superboy with lois lane he's been
featured heavily in a lot of the comics
recently
then crisis happened they did a big
justice league rebirth style twist where
the new version of the multiverse is
way different and they retconned
everyone onto the same earth earth prime
so that they could do more justice
league stuff
when that happened the new backstory is
that superman now has two sons who are
both in high school they're both
teenagers
remember tom welling superman during
smallville season one he was a freshman
in high school
his powers had just started to manifest
one of the sons will be a little bit
older in high school but the younger one
is supposed to be a freshman i believe
so they're around that age where tom
welling superman was doing their
superboy thing with their powers
manifesting
the older one is going to be named john
kent just like comic book superboy the
younger one is going to be named jordan
kent i'm not sure what the jordan is a
reference to but i believe the younger
one
won't start out in episode one with his
powers yet they'll like slowly find out
about his over the series
just remember the later seasons of
smallville when he became an
upperclassman and was using more complex
powers
the older one will be a little bit more
like that number three so superman moves
them back to smallville
they live there at the kent farm and
raise them through their high school
years because their powers are starting
to manifest and go crazy and they didn't
want to raise him in metropolis but lois
lane will still be working for the daily
planet on the series
superman is supposed to be spending most
of his time doing the regular superman
routine around the world like he would
normally do
but also doubling is the paw kent of the
series
so remember on smallville when clark was
doing all the power
training montage scenes learning life
lessons from jonathan ken
superman will be doing that for them on
this tv show
there will be a couple main antagonists
during season one
the first big one is going to be lois
lane's father general sam lane
everybody remembers him from all the
other series there's been a bunch of
versions of that character
but he's being played by dylan walsh on
the news show most of you know him from
some tv series before he's pretty
recognizable
the rumor is is that the other main
antagonist is going to be an alternate
universe version
of lex luthor played by this person just
out to destroy the world's faith in
superman plotting some larger multiverse
plan
related to crisis on infinite earths
they will still have regular earth
prime lex luthor around he's still a
regular character and because it's
superman they can do pretty much any of
the superman villains from the comics
that they want
and because of the crisis on infinite
earth's reboot they can redo
new versions of all the superman
villains they've already done and used
on other shows
they already kind of did that on the
flash tv show where they sort of
reimagined a lot of original flash
rogues as new versions
number two talking about big crossover
stuff grant gustin said that he was
hoping to do more superman flash
crossovers next year because they cross
over so much in the comics it makes
sense that they would do big crossover
episodes
the producers haven't gotten into
specifics about that yet other than to
say superman will be the main star of
next year's big crossover for 2021 but
because of the virus delays none of the
shows are starting till january next
year
they said that they're supposedly doing
full seasons of all the shows
meaning the crossover would still be
around episode 8 or episode 9 of all the
series
and that would wind up airing sometime
in the spring around april
they did say that the crossover is going
to be way smaller than crisis on
infinite earths as you would expect you
can't really go bigger than crisis
so there'll be fewer characters not all
of them are going to cross over from all
the shows just the bigger ones
originally it was going to be sort of a
superman batman kind of thing going on
like world's finest
they said but because of all the drama
going on behind the scenes
they might change some of that plan
there's all the flash batman crossover
stuff happening in the flash movie
in the flash movie itself will start
filming sometime next year so there's
going to be a lot of flash in batman
happening both between the tv shows and
all the movie stuff
it's going to be really fun to see it all
play out and the justice league snyder
cut will also
be rolling out sometime next year too
while all the shows are happening
just in terms of larger justice league
crossover stuff they haven't said when
their first big quote-unquote justice
league episode is going to happen
it sounds like initially they'll be
doing smaller more self-contained
justice league stuff like you'll have
the flash show up on superman you won't
have
every single member of the tv justice
league showing up together
all the time together number one though
in terms of diggle green lantern for
those of you asking he said that he was
moving to
metropolis so that just screams that
they're probably going to be dealing
with that or at least continuing that
story on the superman tv show
they said that when they gave diggle the
green lantern ring there were all kinds
of rules about what they were allowed to
show and what they were allowed to
reference from warner brothers
because of the new hbo green lantern
series they didn't want to trample on
that
and that's really where the big green
lantern stuff is going to be happening
they didn't say when the hbo green
lantern series is supposed to start
though
only that it's going to be focused on
two green lanterns probably
hal jordan and jon stewart and sinestro
it will deal a lot with their backstory
and jump around in time
there's going to be another dc fandom
comic con event in a couple weeks where
there'll be a
bunch more tv trailers so hopefully
they'll give us some more information
when that happens
but that's only a couple weeks away so
of course i'll do videos for all the
footage that they drop
if you guys didn't see it really great
justice league parody the boys season 2
is premiering this friday i will be
doing videos for all those episodes too
it's
super hardcore and amazing if you
haven't seen it yet be sure to check it
out
and as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you'll see those episode
videos when i post them
while you wait for everything click here
for the flash movie trailer that they
released this past weekend
and click here for the new batman
trailer with robert pattinson
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
you!